we've heard the Witcher and now we've
got the walk chair no just kidding this
is great this is great now you know I
love you
welcome to the heavy spoilers show show
me some love as as always I'm your host
definition aka Frank the tank Miller and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down the ending of cursed
obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the series yet and
don't anything rune then I recommend
that you turn off now make sure you drop
a thumbs up if you don't want me to
curse you and subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of cursed
okay so cursed is based on the book of
the same name by Thomas wheeler and
Frank Miller who even makes a cameo at
one point in Episode three the story was
only released in October last year and
it's been a lightning fast turnaround on
the series you can tell netflix are
confident due to their casting of
Kathryn Lankford in the role and she
really makes it her own Lankford of
course gained fame with 13 reasons why
and this new vehicle for her is a
brilliant watch she plays in my FA which
that it's revealed to be the daughter of
Merlin the storyline as a whole is a
sort of remix of the tales of old and
it's season my teaming up with Arthur
himself as they try to score Excalibur
to a dad Merlin has lost his magic and
is no longer as powerful as used to be
and the show takes on many diversions
from the legends that we've come to see
play out time and time again in this
Excalibur is sort of its own entity and
I got a lot of flashes of the Lord of
the Rings with it pretty much being an
extremely powerful weapon that had the
ability to corrupt or empower depending
on who wielded it it's elements like
this that stop it from just being a
MacGuffin
and at least it gains a bit of purpose
because hey who doesn't love seeing
people getting cut in half now the show
is a pretty long journey but the true
Excalibur was the friends we made along
the way know what now there's some fun
little subplots such as my disguising
yourself as a nun and meeting Morgana
The Enchantress in Arthurian legend she
also just happens to be Arthur's sister
and yeah it's nice how they kind of tie
all of the family trees together
Merlin travels to a giant cave to see
Lord rügen he does a horse warp like Red
Dead Redemption one of one of the girls
from the ring travels around the land
trying to kill them way and she and
Arthur discover a Fae resistance group
those are some of the cool little
subplots that really flesh out the
characters but of course every show
needs a villain and in cursed it comes
in the form of the weeping monk and the
red paladin's the weeping monk kind of
kind kind of looks like what you would
draw on your face as a teenager and
think was cool and alongside father
Cardin he and the monks lead the red
paladin's through the countryside
hunting down witches n'aime way is of
course one of these within the first 45
minutes of the show they burned a home
to the ground crucified some of her
people and killed her mother
yikes now I might be reaching here but I
kinda took them as being similar to the
bad guys from world war ii you know the
ones that i can't say because of
monetization on youtube who are hunting
for jewish people and there's a lot of
similarities they they have a cross like
symbol in a circle as their icon which
of course being alongside the color red
is very very prominent again i don't
know if that's me just jumping to
conclusions but i saw a lot of
similarities and I think that the
creative team were trying to show the
audience that hey we're all alike
even if there are certain figure heads
that say we aren't on the other side of
the coin providing hurdles for Merlin is
King Uther and the Queen Mother Luthor
is actually not the true heir to the
throne and he was merely planted there
by the mother after she gave birth to a
stillborn child she murdered his real
mother and covered up the crime but
Merlin is aware of what's going on and
this of course leaves a position for
Arthur to take up the throne later down
the line this doesn't happen in the
season but you can kind of see how
they're laying the groundwork here and
yet setting up things in motion now as
with most remixes the show changes up a
lot of the familiar faces in interesting
and exciting new ways nan way comes face
to face with a father at the halfway
point of the season and a wealth of
things are revealed it's here that she
learns of her lineage and that Excalibur
was actually pulled from Merlin himself
which is what ended up costing him his
magic he fell in love with Lenore her
mother but she was promised to another
and eventually ended up
driving him away because of the sword it
turns out that Merlin actually ransacked
Rome and slaughtered the people there
which eventually led to the creation of
the vengeful red paladins and thus he's
been trying to keep away from the sword
in order to stop the temptation it
brings Merlin in my end up becoming
divided and the ending of the season
heads to all-out war with the red
paladins fighting the Fae whilst Merlin
journeys to the Kings nan way becomes
the fake queen okay
the slay queen but a days are soon
numbered when she's marked for death
this kind of plays into the ending and
were told that nothing can stop it from
happening
Merlin wishes to destroy the sword but
he realizes that his daughter's fate is
now tied to it and makes a deal with the
forces of cumber a Viking King to hand
it over in exchange for her the Green
Knight also goes head-to-head with the
weeping monk the monk gets the upper
hand and takes him captive but during
the faceoff he discovers that the monk
is actually a Fae the Green Knight could
reveal his secret but he doesn't due to
the mantra of the Fae which is that they
are all equals this definitely has a
huge sway on the monk who's later
revealed to be Lancelot and arguably
comes as one of the biggest twists in
the entire season he slowly starts to
realize that his place isn't with the
red paladins and arguably goes on the
biggest arc in the entire season slowly
changing from villain to hero in
addition to this we discover that the
young character he's with called
squirrel who tries to rescue the night
is really Percival and that the red
spear is headed up by Quinn appear if
you're not familiar with our theory and
legend then these are all kind of
connected to author as either members of
the knights of the round table or his
wife respectively yes Arthur he does
hook up with the red spear but then
Lancelot he does a little August Elina
now in the final two episodes Luther
poisons the Queen Mother as a way to get
revenge for the mother that she murdered
but in doing so he also proves in some
way that he's a perp
to her it's a really chilling scene that
shows he actually did become her true
son
because only her true son would ever
murder their own mother and it really
hammers home the entire quest for power
that I think is the big theme in the
show everyone seems to be willing to
take power even at the cost of their own
cells and we slowly watches the quest
for the throne and the sword corrupts
all men weight is given the option to
either hand us up over to come back or
Luthor and even our own people started
its trustor Morgana also makes a deal
with the ghost of her dead lover in
order to pass the sword to death and add
to that little iris is coming for nem
way and you really start to second-guess
what her fate will be now upon
discovering that Merlin knows of the
truth about his past he locks up the
wizard and in ways people are seemingly
saved she hands herself over to you
there but it doesn't take the sword with
her and the fair attacked on the shore
by comers forces as they try and make
their escape this leads to a huge vowel
and it definitely feels like a high
point in the series the weeping monk has
a change of heart
rescues squirrel and fights for his life
against his own kind elsewhere NIM way
finds the body of the Green Knight and
is then captured by father Cardin this
is when death arrives and she's actually
revealed to be Morgana now it's a bit
difficult to tell what exactly went on
due to the scene becoming animated for
some reason but it turns out Morgana
killed death and thus someone needed to
take death's place so she was forced
into the position death passes Excalibur
tanam way who then he uses it to behead
Cardin and thus they're finally free of
him now due to her abilities
Morgana consents that Merlin is at
death's door and he goes to him along
with NIM way they escape from the
Paladin camp but it's at this moment
that iris finally gets a wish and she
shows up to kill NIM way firing an arrow
into her that makes a tumble of a
waterfall and you know what yet as much
as I didn't like Iris initially I was
kind of pleased to say I get this little
moment you know no shade in him where
you put yeah you go iris it's at this
point that Merlin picks up the sword and
Nursery gains his power and iris flees
as the Paladin
arrived to attack him however due to his
ability he easily takes them out and
basically becomes Thor at the end of
Thor Ragnarok what happens the iris will
shock you and millon grapples with the
power that has returned to him he grabs
Morgana and the two teleport away which
is the last time that we see them in the
season
iris is taken into a church and she's
given a mask likely going forward as a
big villain for the second season it's
gonna be kind of interesting to see the
arc that she goes on and I actually
think that she might also do what the
weeping monk did and end up turning
against her people she was a very lost
soul that clearly just wanted a home no
matter the cost and I think that she's
gonna be a very interesting character
going forward now I'm in ways seemingly
dies however mixed in with the ascension
of iris we actually get a scene in which
we can see her in a lake you might
remember that this was shown at the
opening of the season duties what was
coming ahead and though it seems like
the character drowns is actually a lot
that we can take from this now firstly
we need to look into our theory and
legend itself and see who NIM way really
was now NIM way has taken up many many
names and monikers for the one that you
may know her best for is the Lady of the
lake according to the legend she gave
Excalibur to Arthur and took him back
upon his death reaching up into the air
as the sword was cast back into the body
of water she also helped to raise
Lancelot after the death of his father
and though I don't think that this will
be completely carried over I do think
that the seasons going forward will pay
with it in some way Lancelot has of
course just lost father Cardin his
surrogate dad and I do think that she
will help to guide him through embracing
his fááááá bilities the fact that NIM
way also dropped into water does make it
seem like she will be gaining new powers
and an ability to be at one with it thus
giving her the title of the Lady of the
lake I don't believe that she's dead as
Morgana had of course gain new abilities
and she would be able to sense where the
name way was about to pass or not and
she didn't she's likely still alive and
kicking and now you may think that the
other premonitions uttered by the
preceding death character did warn of
this coming in I believe that Morgana
stopped this when she saved her life so
yet I can't see them killing off the
main character before the second season
but hey game of their own stated so why
not now before we get into the review I
just wanna let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the MCU infinity
Saga box set to one random subscriber
all you have to do to being with a
chance of winning it's like the video
and leave your thoughts on the series in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
August and the set will be shipped out
from then Tova gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
okay so what did I think of cursed well
though I've seen some people complaining
about it kind of forcing diversity and
making female empowerment take center
stage I personally don't feel like it
was too forced and at least to me Nym
way is definitely a more flawed
character rather than a Mary Sue who
just so happens to be good at everything
I can see a lot of people disagreeing
with that but to me she gets blindsided
by a kid at the end of the show and
throughout whenever she doesn't have
Excalibur it does feel like her backs
against the wall and yeah I found it
believable for for a show about witches
and stuff
now it's also nice to see Frank Miller
portraying women that aren't ladies of
the night for once and I did appreciate
the characterizations
I can't lie this has some pretty high
production values and some nice plays on
the original legend that keep things
feeling fresh and not as derivative as
they should be for something that's
probably being adapted over a thousand
times I feel like there were some flaws
and you know the pacing was a bit off
from time to time and if I was to change
anything I would have cut down a lot of
the subplots and probably got this at
eight hours as I feel like that run time
would have probably covered all of the
same ground but left it feeling a lot
brisket however for a new property with
the first season that's trying to
reinvent the wheel I did enjoy it
overall I'm excited to see what happens
next and cursed gets an 8 out of 10
okay so that's our breakdown of cursed
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so comment below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
drop a thumbs up if you want something
else to watch it then make sure you
check out our breakdown of the old guard
which is going to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content too early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord linked in the description or at
heavy spoilers on Twitter hopefully I
see you over there but if not have a
lovely weekend it's been nice talking to
you and hopefully I'll see you next time
take care